but you know one thing we did that was
so great I fired Comey very early and a
lot of people said oh you should have
done it well you know they're giving a
term
they'd give it a turn very early
not immediately early but very early
early in a few months and I got rid of
this guy and by doing that it was like
you threw a rock at a hornet's nest the
whole thing collapsed you saw the Love
Letters back and forth with the
different people talking about the
insurance policy you know what the
insurance policy that was against me
that was how to issue for some reason
loses darling we have an insurance
policy the insurance policies they'll
get me out one way or the other they'll
get me out because you know what this is
30 35 years of being put into government
and you get there and initially I didn't
know people in Washington I was there 17
times in my entire life I never stayed
over never stayed over before this all
of a sudden I'm president of the United
States I relate and we had tremendous
people also don't forget biggest tax
cuts in history biggest regulation Cuts
in history rebuilt our military took out
ices cookout solomani took out Al
baghdadi the two biggest terrorists in
the world I mean what we did was
incredible strongest border we've ever
had everything was good no inflation
best economy in history we did all of
this stuff we had tremendous we had
tremendous people look they made a lot
of money yeah no no so we had tremendous
people but we also had some you rely on
others you rely on people that you knew
you rely on other politicians to give
you answers and you find out that they
are rhinos or they gave you bad advice
so we had some that weren't good but
when you think Comey had a term he had
many years left in that term I said this
guy's bad news I realized it very early
very early in the administration I fired
him and it was wild that's when we found
out all of the corruption had I not
fired Comey you wouldn't know any of the
things that you were talking about you
think they would have destroyed you well
they were trying to take me out yeah
they were trying to take me I mean it
was like a coup it was like a coup had I
not you know it's very interesting some
people that are very smart that you know
very well
said when I did it oh that was a mistake
that was a mistake you're going to cause
now they say it was the greatest
instinctual move they've ever seen
because Comey was a very bad guy and
Comey LED that group of thugs in there
and they were doing a number they were
it's very dishonest it's years and years
of putting in people Democrats and
rhinos and other people but putting them
into office and we got rid of a lot of
them but we're going to get rid of a lot
more a lot more because you have some
bad
question
in the past
[Music]
hey I'm like you I think we should have
paper ballots same-day voting make
Election Day a national holiday
and have partisan observers in every
preseason watching the voters and then
watching the vote counting and when the
polls close declare a winner game over
right but that's not the system we have
Republicans have been reluctant and
resisted towards early voting mail-in
voting and it and they've also been
resistant towards legal ballot
harvesting which Democrats have mastered
which is why they can hide in their
basement run hundreds of millions of
dollars in ads and and never answer a
press question or shake a hand or kiss a
baby or do a town hall my question is do
you now encourage and embrace early and
voting voting by mail and legal ballot
harvesting I do but I also have to say
something else because the one thing a
lot of people but this is important
including you don't talk about they also
create phony ballots and that's a real
problem that's my opinion what they
created a lot of phony balance has your
mind shifted in other words I think if
Republicans start out election day down
200 300 500 000 votes that's that
becomes nearly impossible to catch up
with for some reason Republicans always
wanted to go out on Tuesday and they
wanted to vote I respect that I think
it's great and it would be great if we
could get back to one day and we all the
things that you said with one thing with
you with voter ID with voter ID because
the Democrats don't signature
verification how about this they don't
want voter ID because they want to cheat
you know they want to cheat they don't
want voter ID even the Democrats regular
Democrat people want voter ID but the
leaders don't because they can't cheat
the one thing we have to be very careful
of is phony ballots everything you say
is great but they create balance that's
my opinion and that's the opinion of a
lot of people will you encourage your
voters based on the system we have
to go along with the system of early
voting and voting by mail because I
think if you don't you it's a big
mistake oh no no I will but those
ballots get lost also Sean you know they
send them in and all of a sudden they're
gone those ballots get lost also the
answer is I will because you would like
it but you know what can I be honest for
me okay but a lot I got to take a break
but Sean a lot of bad things happen to
those ballots also they're sent in early
and all of a sudden where are they bet
look we have very corrupt elections we
have no borders if you don't have
borders and if you don't have good
elections you don't have a country and
that's where we are but I'm okay by the
end of by the end of this year we'll
probably have under Joe Biden nearly 8
million illegal immigrants since he's
been president quick break more of our
exclusive town hall with President
Donald J Trump Straight Ahead we're
going to take questions from the
audience hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else